I think garage saleing there's the Big Roi play
Because the garage sale ebay conversion has some of the biggest margins in the world. What are we asking for these days?
I don't even know Vanessa [russ]
[I]
truly believe that it that every person can make a thousand dollars a week by
Waking up at 5 o'clock in the morning garage [saling] on a Saturday for four hours and then posting this stuff. They find on eBay
Have any video games
What do you think air looks the best City can you do?
in Pilatus Porter was
I like it. That's a serious thing
[I] think it [actually] [is] because a lot [of] people like how do I make money like it's right
they are like literally become educated on vhS and DVD and
Cd like arbitrage of a because everybody's selling them at garage sales like three bucks for [a] box of them
And you'll make a thousand [dollars] every weekend. This is Gonna be the charm box
You know 40 to 200 boys and girls
All the pieces are 150 they make a hundred fifty bucks in ten seconds at 7:30 in the morning set
We have to we have to quote excuse why do you fucks that'll make everything
Direct you're working at a squirrel
It's very who wants a thousand dollars every week very practical person all right. [I] like practicality